pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieuse et les épis curieux ça va
mais petit chou pas de panique
je parle à mes légumes l1 version
miniature du chou pommé ou choux cabus
suivant les appellations régionales
lui c'est le chou de bruxelles mais
pourquoi de bruxelles est pas d'ailleurs
parce qu'à l'origine ce petit chou vient
de belgique du village de saint gilles
situé dans la banlieue de la capitale du
royaume belge
mais pourquoi est il si petit
[Musique]
eh bien au milieu du xviie siècle
l'augmentation de la population de la
métropole oblige les maraîchers
bruxellois a trouvé les solutions pour
accroître les rendements tout en
utilisant le moins de terres cultivables
possible à partir d'une variété que l'on
trouve sur la côte atlantique qui pousse
à hauteur et qui est destiné au bétail
ils réussissent à force de sélection à
produire dans la banlieue de la capitale
belge
une nouvelle variété de chou elle se
présente sous la forme d'une longue tige
d'environ un mètre de hauteur d'eau
surgissent des bourgeons en forme de
petites pommes d'environ 3 centimètres
les belges développe un tel savoir faire
sur cette variété qui la protègent
jusqu'au 19ème siècle les agriculteurs
français devait demander leurs semences
aux grainetier du roi de belgique
aujourd'hui le chou de bruxelles est
cultivé apprécié surtout en europe du
nord et les plus friands sont nos
voisins britanniques qui le servent
lors de leur repas de noël comme tous
les choix feuilles les choux de
bruxelles contiennent des composés
soufrés ces composés sont souvent
indigeste et provoque des flatulences
pour les consommer il est donc
préférable de les faire blanchir c'est à
dire les faire bouillir 5 minutes dans
un grand volume d'eau salée
cette première cuisson permet d'éliminer
une partie des composés soufrés qui vont
se dissoudre dendre ensuite on les
écoute et on les fait cuire à la vapeur
ou dorer à la poêle
en fin de cuisson j'y ajoute
personnellement un petit filet de
vinaigre
ça relève le goût de ce shoot bruxelles
essayé une fois
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus merci les
épis curieux pour les plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]